hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and you know what time it is time for
another SpongeBob horror game this one
called nightmare in squidville there's a
Prelude it's on YouTube
[Music]
oh wait a minute no well this will just
give me copyrights Trucking so I'm not
gonna do that it's just the episode
where Squidward goes to squidville
so in case you didn't know what it was
it is Squidward going to squidville all
right I'm going into it
hey SpongeBob wake up we must find
Squidward it's already dark
ah I must have fallen asleep
let us knock on some doors to find out
where he is
click left to not oh
too fast
hold on there
hold on I'm going with old point one
ah a little too much
point two
perfect I
I love the fact that they've got the
janky AI voices going on
well this is unsettling
yep all right I'm just gonna go knock on
some doors
hello have you seen Squidward
hello
anybody seem Squidward
nope okay
uh Patrick oh
hi wait a minute wait wait a minute
Patrick hi Joe
what
hello have you seen Squidward I'm sure I
just didn't
[Music]
where is everybody I don't know
I don't know
we just got here
should be a vibrant town full of people
dancing playing clarinet
and such and the like has that
did you hear this
did I hear what you said that like you
have some news
Patrick you keep an eye out okay buddy
okay
right
a track where are you
hmm
nobody opens that does not seem to work
uh-huh well I'm gonna keep trying
Patrick
where are you buddy how
well I'm starting to think this might be
futile there seems to be a fire over
here
I wonder if I'm
supposed to go towards that
probably
hello
[Music]
Squidward is that you
uh
[Music]
you Patrick anywhere
okay okay
this is fine
it's real good
crashed
did he
dead
okay all right then fine
it's all good okay uh
uh a patch
ing up there the jellyfish that better
be a jellyfish and not a disembodied
Squidward head floating through the sky
I have a funny feeling that's a
disembodied Squidward head floating
through the sky Lexi and zoom oh God
don't Zoom what was that
oh
okay
Bud Squidward
Squidward
Woodward
[Music]
okay
I have a funny feeling um that maybe we
should give up on our hunt or otherwise
we're gonna meet an untimely end
I'm over here
one of the Fantastic shops in this
lovely place
oh Patrick
I was so worried about you
trick where have you been I was just
looking for something to eat
sorry
that's okay buddy
that's okay good thing you got such a
thick skull
well you can't find them Patrick so we
might as well just get out of here how
we how did we get here I don't remember
searching
is that a ghost
is that is that a ghost
[Music]
mildly concerning all right Patrick
stick close and don't get distracted
there's something going on up here
oh yeah that's a ghost story
I didn't know the Flying Dutchman has a
bicycle
what did you just what what
oh it's a ghost bicycle
yeah okay oh I I don't have my license
Patrick are you okay
[Music]
why
hi uh there's a park over here
definitely not gonna look up
Squidward
Patrick you see anything
uh
grabbing your attention
all right then ah hi
never mind
uh
oh okay Patrick okay Patrick go to that
other switch
oh oh okay maybe we must press the
button at the same time maybe let me
count it press what do you say so okay
whoa whoa what comes next you didn't
even get it right
no
I was not really oh my God let me count
it press what do you say so
a horse well
whoa what's comes back
no
no I was not ready no
okay all right we got it we got there
buddy we got there Squidward uh what
happened in here you all right buddy
there is footwork yeah there he is we
have been looking for you all day hey
Squidward why are you in a cage
SpongeBob's Patrick I am happy to see
you really would you be some kind and
help me out
the tentacle acres is a trap they know
me here they are cannibals they had even
the other ones I am next
I tried to fly away with the leaf blower
but I cracked so they knocked me out of
threw me a cage
and the kid must be somewhere near you
maybe you see them gathered at the park
please hang in there we see what we can
do either we find the care there is
another way
yes
yes all right okay this makes total
sense
um are you talking right here hey guys
what is this Patrick this does not look
good
or what what what right
uh don't mind me hello hi you mind if I
just wait a minute
all right okay all right well why not
just uh calm down there a little Patrick
run
run uh peekaboo oh
all right it's creepy
uh
I'm just gonna
uh cell phone
I got the key
well
I think this is gonna definitely get you
free Squidward
don't you worry about a thing buddy
oh okay
uh
sorry it's difficult to turn around
where did Patrick go also why does it
sound like they're about to drop an
atomic bomb
I don't know what is that
I'm trying uh
sorry uh pardon me
excuse me pardon me well I don't know
about that
because they don't seem to be any
impediment to my driving ability so I'm
pretty sure that we're fine
all right pardon me oops
all right
well that was easy oh God where are we
that was Rising who do you mean hell's
Rising
this in front of us
what we get through this nightmare what
what
[Music]
I'm sorry I didn't know that I was going
into the tunnel of Despair I clearly
would have gone somewhere else
um how did it how did it
what are you even shooting at me
how did I get here how did any of this
occur you didn't do you understand my
questions I have so many
um so
Squidward uh I have to ask
how did you not notice any of this when
you first got here I mean maybe it was a
thing when they
lured you in here with false promises
and then as soon as you cross the
threshold you couldn't leave but I I
just have to say it's pretty uh pretty
obviously demonic
okay
[Applause]
we gonna go yeah
I have the burning leaf blower let's
claim this place what what do you mean I
have the burning Reef bro what what
oh my God
uh oh
I need to find more fuel okay I'll do
that
[Music]
oh my God
yeah Squidward I don't mean to like
if you let me know if I'm uh
if I'm being overly judgmental but um
seems like just
squids in general
seem to be
horted
at plain old evil
um and again I don't mean to be
judgmental but are you sure that you
didn't turn into one of these things
Allah the thing or maybe you were always
like this
and again I feel like
I feel like this might reflect poorly on
me but you can see what we're dealing
with today
I feel like we just have to be certain
of it
and I don't know how this fell upon me
to deal out Justice in this way
you understand right okay
it is awesome I'm not gonna lie this is
an awesome turn
the music is great
[Music]
I I've got no words I don't have any
idea what to say
God what is happening to me
[Music]
why
oh you was that you oh good oh good
Ness
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna redo this
you hold on there you go oh I see what
happened ah that makes sense okay but uh
how do I cleanse this place for good
is it even possible it seems to be
thinning out but then again I can't
really tell
it just seems to be an unending horde of
them
is there some kind of Heart of evil like
you know well never mind I'm done
also how does fire work underwater
I guess that was always a question
SpongeBob thank you SpongeBob you saved
us yeah thank you Patrick you did
nothing
[Music]
oh that's nice
I said that is that is nice I've
[Music]
I mean this is really thorough
credits the attributions are just
beautiful
you have uncredited the tutorial that
you read or watched wow
I gotta say I didn't know what the hell
to think of that game as I was playing
it
super creepy at first and then
I mean
I I just applaud the credits given
credit to absolutely everything even
down to the fonts even down to the
tutorial very impressive
what am I listening to
from you now
[Music]
you are not wrong
all right well I think that this
concludes the game
what an experience I think this is uh
SpongeBob horror elevated to an art form
I don't even know what to think I don't
even know what to feel so I'm just gonna
leave it there thanks one more SpongeBob
horror look it up on my channel
you know how to find it thanks for
watching
hope this is royalty free
maybe we'll see and as always I'll see
you
in the next video
bye-bye what the [__] it's amazing
[Music]